today on the matt wall show it's well
known that the people who shout follow
the science are often the most hostile
to it the latest example is the left's
campaign to
censor a book about the quote
transgender craze among children
so we'll talk about that today also in
our five headlines chicago becomes the
latest city to cancel thanksgiving
no thanksgiving is allowed uh the mayor
says it's necessary to do this in order
to save lives but she seems very
selective
in the lives she wants to save in her
city plus cracker barrel apologizes for
a rope that offended people in its store
plus our daily cancellation and much
more but first
a word from our good friends at charity
mobile you know we we talk about we
complain about i know i complain all the
time about
companies so many companies out there
big corporations especially that don't
share our values uh as conservatives and
pro-lifers
and are actively working to undermine uh
us in the culture and in fact we'll have
an example of that coming up in just a
second here
but that's why when there's a when
there's a company that does share our
values and is on our side it's so
important to support them
and that's what brings us to the
pro-life phone company charity mobile
uh you know with with charity mobile
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
and that's the the charity part of it
and that's great but there's also the
service part where you get a great
service as well new activations and
eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
uh look there's no contracts there's no
termination fees there's no risk there's
a 30-day guarantee so you don't have to
worry about anything like that
and there's live customer service based
right in the usa whenever you need it
and if you know if you've got kids and
you want to make sure you're protecting
them as well
you got the ability to block cellular
data picture messages text messages
whatever you want to do
for that for that safety with your kids
as well which is so important you can
help build a culture of life in america
while supporting a pro-life phone
company and also getting a great service
on top of that
and i've been using charity mobile for
months now and i can't say enough good
things about it
so what i would tell you right now is
call them at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with
them online at charitymobile.com
all right well you know we're constantly
told these days to
follow the science believe in science
the science will guide us
the science will save us all hail
science our redeemer
this is a message we have heard
especially during the covet lockdowns
which have been justified on the basis
of
science and by on the basis of science i
mean on the basis of the word itself
this is usually how science is wielded
in arguments these days in order to
prove that science is on one side
one need only shout the words science
and research and evidence
while providing actual examples of none
of them
you know like do your research haven't
you ever heard of science you dummy
look at the evidence and that's all
that's the whole argument loud and
confident assertion in the place of
persuasion which pretty much sums up
all debate on the internet these days
and much of what you get from the left
in this country
the left is especially fond of of
talking about science though not
necessarily as fond of the thing
itself yesterday on the show uh just as
an example i played a strange little
skit
from the demented mayor of chicago uh uh
celebrating science ostensibly and it's
really not necessary that i play it
again but i'm going to anyway just to
torture you and so here it is
[Music]
thank god science is back baby
and the earth is round
not flat washing your hands
does work social distancing
does matter and wearing a face covering
does help protect all of us
i do love science
yes you're welcome for that don't take
me off or i might keep playing that
that will be my punishment for the
audience any time it misbehaves
the lori lightfoot videos will continue
until morale improves
but in any case you see their science
science is back
and of course governor cuomo in new york
is a big fan of talking about science he
said that
following science is the reason why he's
decided to
as we discussed yesterday take the
absurdly unconstitutional step of
telling people
how many family members they're allowed
to have in their own homes what this has
to do with science and
how science it all vindicates this move
is not explained
it's never explained and it's
interesting that from the
follow science and believe in science
crowd
you also get this abigail schreier wrote
a book called
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters
and it's about as the title suggests
left-wing gender ideology and how it's
being imposed on our children
here's a description of the book on
amazon i think it's important to
understand what the book is about so
that
the madness of what we're going to
discuss next is perfectly clear
so the description says until just a few
years ago gender dysphoria severe
discomfort in one's biological sex was
vanishingly rare it was typically found
in less than .01
of the population emerged in early
childhood and afflicted males almost
exclusively but today whole groups of
female
friends in colleges high schools and
even middle schools across the country
are coming out as transgender
these are girls who had never
experienced any discomfort in their
biological sex
until they heard a coming out story from
a speaker at a school assembly or
discovered the internet community of
trans
influencers unsuspecting parents are
awakening to find their daughter's
enthrall to hip
trans youtube stars and gender affirming
educators and therapists
who push life-changing interventions on
young girls including medically
unnecessary double mastectomies
and puberty blockers that can cause
permanent infertility abigail schreier a
writer for the wall street
journal has dug deep into the trans
epidemic
talking to the girls their agonized
parents and the counselors and doctors
who enable
gender transitions as well as to
detransitioners young women who bitterly
regret what they've done to themselves
coming out as transgender immediately
boosts these girls social status driver
finds
but once they take the first steps of
transition it's not easy to walk back
she offers urgently needed advice about
how parents can protect their daughters
okay sounds like a great book an
important book i'd heard of the book
before it hadn't read it
i've now ordered a copy of it myself but
the more important point
is that it's a book talking about a very
real phenomenon
and calling attention to a problem that
many people would prefer to ignore
it's also a book it would seem grounded
in science that is grounded in the
recognition of
the reality of biological sex and child
psychology
it is through the recognition of these
two realities and through understanding
them that a person can see that the
transgender craze among children is a
problem
it's a crisis in fact but the
pro-science people
um don't like this kind of science so
the woke squad has been
hounding schreier and trying to get her
shut down and censored and going after
anyone who sells the books yesterday
a couple of a trans activists and it was
just a couple from what i could tell
tweeted at target complaining that the
forbidden text was on sale in their
stores
target within hours very quickly
responded and pulled the book from their
shelves
all it took was a few trans activists
just shouting the word transphobia
and targets a multi-billion dollar
company caved in
like a quaking sinkhole and apologized
and said they'd remove it
just like that it must be nice to wield
that kind of
cultural power i mean trans people say
they're oppressed by our society and yet
just one or two of them can go to target
and say i don't much care for this
product you're selling
and the whole company will fall to its
knees beg for forgiveness
remove whatever item was distressing
them do you think i could get that
response
do you think i as the dreaded privileged
cisgender white man
could go to target and say hey target
get rid of this book here
i don't like it and they would actually
say yes sir as you wish
i doubt it now once i'm fascist dictator
of the hemisphere you could be damn sure
they'll listen but for now not so much
because i'm not so lucky as to be
oppressed in that way
in the way that so many groups in
america are quote oppressed
by the way as mentioned there's been a
lot of censorship around this book and
of course
uh this issue more broadly um this week
also gofundme shut down a fundraiser by
a group of parents
who are trying to raise money to put up
billboards that were supposed to combat
the manipulation and corruption of
children by the radical lgbt lgbt
left the billboard said puberty is not a
medical condition
and then there was a picture of
schreier's book and a message urging
people to read it
gofundme stopped the fundraiser citing
their rules against
hate speech and this is what you get if
you
follow the science in the way that the
left wants you to namely
they want you to follow not the science
but doctrine
and they want you to follow it all the
way over a cliff and into the abyss
see the thing is following science i
mean actually following signs
if the phrase means anything at all must
mean
simply weighing all the information
available
analyzing it coolly and rationally and
making informed judgments
science after all is not some sort of
creature it's not some entity it's not
some mysterious
being that commands our allegiance
science is the study of the physical and
natural world
and following science means means it
means not not blindly accepting whatever
someone tells you in the supposed name
of science
but rather approaching issues as
objectively as possible
and drawing conclusions based on an
honest analysis of the available
information
it'd probably be better to say instead
of follow the science
as if the science is some homogeneous
never-changing
thing which issues decrees like the
wizard and the wizard of oz
instead maybe we should say think
scientifically or maybe even better
putting the word science to the side we
might just tell people to be honest
to be rational be thoughtful that's
really what's needed in our society
but whether we're endeavoring to follow
the science think scientifically or
simply be honest and rational
none of that is possible if entire
categories of thought
are forbidden if volumes of research and
evidence on a given subject are thrown
in the incinerator
because they might offend the wrong
people if perfectly valid and
intelligent points of view are not
allowed to be expressed
or are are shouted down rather than
listened to and engaged with
i mean if you really want to follow the
science and you don't agree with
schreier or people like her
then present your arguments against her
make your case
say i disagree here's why
you'll have quite a hard row in front of
you if you want to make an argument
against schreier's view
that we shouldn't push gender confusion
on our children
but if that's your view defend it the
problem is that most of the people with
that view the opposing viewers triers
know they can't defend it they can't
begin to make a coherent case
so they scream and shout and pout and
punish and censor
of course all the while still extolling
the virtues of
quote unquote science
all right let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
all right getting into our headlines um
by the way i mentioned before i have all
these uh these stage props on my on my
desk now my fancy new studio like i have
my nashville my fake nashville family
and my um who i i draw a lot of
inspiration from i also have i just
noticed i have
these fake books i have a a book that
was put here
on the title it says band names that's
the name that's the title of the book
band names and then it's it's empty
inside
so i don't know if it's a book if i come
up with ideas for band names
i guess i'm supposed to just keep track
of those here which is good because i
have a lot of ideas for bad names i have
no
musical ability but in fact i just had
one what did i say i i made a mental
note
um oh the quaking sinkholes
might be a good name for a band someone
could take that i'll have to write that
in the book
all right um number one speaking of
mayor lightfoot
uh let's play that video again no i'm
not gonna do that
but here's the latest from chicago
democratic chicago mayor lori lightfoot
issued another lockdown advisory on
thursday as cover 19 cases spike in her
city
uh urging chicagoans to cancel their
thanksgiving plans starting monday
lightfoot will impose a 10 person
ceiling on gatherings such as weddings
funerals and other events
she said a state-home advisory for
chicago will go into effect on monday
november 16th at 6 a.m
this advisory calls on all chicagoans to
do the following
stay home unless for essential reasons
stop having guests over
including family members you don't live
with
avoid non-essential travel cancel
traditional thanksgiving plans
regarding whether the advisory is
mandatory or voluntary lightfoot said
this is a progressive step i hope we
don't have to go any further than this
you know we've been so focused on the
war
on christmas we've been manning the
forts on the war on christmas
and instead they just they they uh
sneaked in the side entrance and
canceled thanksgiving instead
uh but she also says i want to read this
she says uh if the possibility of a
thousand more people dying in the city
in the next seven weeks doesn't grab you
by the throat as it did me
when i started seeing that modeling then
there's little we're going to do to move
you
uh if we see you violating these rules
in any way we're not going to hesitate
to take action
yeah well of course you read something
like that from the mayor of chicago
and the first thing that comes to mind
is yeah you know you got hundreds of
people dying in your city
uh all every year nothing to do with
cove at 19.
i mean murdering each other in the
streets you don't seem very concerned
about that okay i i would think
that should quote grab you by the throat
shouldn't it mayor
not a lot of concern there no instead
we're gonna we're gonna make sure
stop having guests over i mean i i know
i've been complaining about this all
week but
i i will never get used to that
you've got the mayor of a city or the
governor of a state
telling you you can't stop having guests
over to your house
it is absolute madness
um all right number two we'll play this
here's yet another segment from cnn
comparing trump to hitler
listen this week 82 years ago
crystal enough happened it was the
nazi's warning shot across the bow of
our human civilization
that led to genocide against a whole
identity
and in that tower of burning books it
led to an attack on fact knowledge
history and truth after four years of a
modern day assault on those same values
by donald trump
the biden harry's team pledges a return
to norm
yeah that's one of the more direct
comparisons we've heard
from uh from an outlet like cnn of
course it's not the first time we've
gotten this comparison they've been
doing this for four years but
one of them one of the more direct
comparisons of course completely
ridiculous
and also offensive uh considering you
know the holocaust
is a thing that actually happened and
millions of people died so
it's not just some political cudgel that
you can use or you shouldn't be using it
that way it's not some pawn to be
to be played with in your political
games um and also as i've as i've
said the the the attempt i mean there
there are plenty of legitimate
criticisms
you can make of donald trump um which is
why it's so impressive
that with all these legitimate and there
are plenty of legitimate criticisms you
can make of any president or any
politician
donald trump though has you know has has
his own share
um many of which are pretty obvious but
with all these legitimate criticisms you
can make of donald trump
somehow the left in the media has spent
the last four years
focusing on everything but those
they found they they've been focusing on
all the illegitimate criticisms
completely bypassing the huge elephant
in the room which are the real
criticisms they could be making
trying to paint trump as some sort of
dictator-like figure which is which is
just the absolute opposite of the truth
i think one of his weaknesses has been
that he he
he's he's uh he's a
you know especially when it comes to the
with the rioting and everything that
happened
he was very reluctant actually to step
in
uh and uh and and put a stop to it i
don't think
a dictator would have that reluctance
donald trump was
right number three this is from yahoo
uh listen to this story
this again this is yahoo it's not
babylon b this is real
a cracker barrel location in connecticut
has recently come under fire after the
discovery of a decoration
that closely resembled a noose cracker
barrels are often decorated with antique
and vintage items but according to fox
news patron alfonso robinson
noticed newslike decorations notice
noose like it's not a noose it's just
noose like
in other words if it's a rope with a
knot at the end
now that's noose like um
according to fox news patron alfonso
robinson noticed new slight decorations
while dining at the restaurant november
9th
and posted pictures of them to twitter
he said someone at cracker barrel in
east windsor needs to explain why there
are nooses on the ceiling
the chain responded to the tweet the
same day apologizing
uh saying we work hard to create a
culture of hospitality that's welcoming
respectful and inclusive to everyone who
walks through our doors
some of the historic decor in our stores
may be reminiscent of earlier times but
our inclusive culture
is firmly grounded in today how is a
rope reminiscent of earlier times
it's just a rope cracker bear also
clarified the decoration was an antique
soldering iron
with an original wrapped cord that
should have been noticed and corrected
before ever being displayed
and it's now gone from the store you
were offended by the rope so he took it
down
after the incident local activists have
met with the manager of the store in
order to do a walk-through
of the store and point out any other
decorations that may have a racist
connotation
any other decorations but this one
didn't have a racist connotation it was
a soldering iron
what's racist about that
uh it's still unclear if the chain will
check its other locations for other
decorations that could be viewed as
racist well you might
any anything can be viewed as right i
think we've learned that much by now
literally anything can be viewed as
racist
this is this is this is the one talent
that the left has and the race hustlers
have
this their creativity and finding
ways to see everything as racist so
anything could be right you guys will
just take everything down
uh every building has to be
utterly bare just white walls like in
the matrix or something
you know when neo steps into the matrix
right before he does the karate lesson
it's all just
but i guess actually never mind white
walls would also be offensive
um karen prescott founder of a local
organization to fight racism told the
publication
um that is the journal enquirer
publication says
i am hopeful that the interaction i had
with the manager here today
is what's going to be what it's going to
be like going forward with any
businesses individuals organizations or
people on social media
basically what i'm saying is if if i can
say to you hey this is racist this is
offensive then i hope you would move to
action
and in this case take it down and be and
be understanding and be open to learning
first of all open to learning no you
need to be open to learning
because they told you what the rope was
there for so you were just wrong
you're the one who needs to learn here
what you need to learn is not every rope
is racist in fact
i would say this no rope is racist
there's never been a racist rope
it's a robe and also
since even if it was not a noose it was
just a rope
but since wha since when is a noose a a
a universal racist
symbol when did that happen
it's the left has just done this they've
just over the last few months
they've cr they've made this into a
racist symbol just like they did with
the okay side
they just decided that okay that's going
to be racist now that's a calling card
for white nationalists
it never actually was they've simply
decided that it's going to be now
but karen prescott says um i get a load
of
i just listen to this quote again get a
load of this
i i'm hopeful that the interaction i had
with the manager here today
is what it's going to be like going
forward with any businesses individuals
organizations or people
so what she i don't know if this is a he
or she karen spelled with an e
um of course it's a karen though so what
this person is saying is that uh yes i i
i hope that this interaction with
cracker barrel extends to all people
in the world now i i hope this is the
beginning of a trend
where if i tell you that something
offends me you will immediately stop
doing it
this is what they're saying this is what
i expect of the entire world now
and they get their way you know for so
long
those of us on the on the right um
comforted ourselves when we looked at
all these
snowflake safe space college students
and what do we always say we always said
oh they're gonna get out into the real
world
and they're gonna they're gonna discover
that people don't care about their
feelings and
you know they're gonna have a rude
wake-up wake-up call when they get into
the real world
but we forgot that they're inheriting
they
they're inheriting the new world the
world they they're you know they they
get to
shape it they're the new generation so
they just went out into the world and
no actually they haven't really had a
wake-up call
now everyone is just bending to their
whim entire corporations
all right um five finally a report from
usa today
an amazon driver found he was a few
strokes high at a michigan
golf course over the weekend bill offer
spotted something unusual blocking his
way through a cart tunnel about 2 30 p.m
you can see the picture
here at a golf club there was an amazon
delivery truck
wedged about six feet into the tunnel
between the dunes
course ninth green and the clubhouse um
and yeah that's uh so he was he was now
here's
he said he was using gps and that's the
punch line here
so the amazon delivery guy ended up on a
golf course
off the road wedged into a golf course
tunnel
a tunnel that really does not look like
it would fit that truck at all and it
didn't
but he was just following the gps and we
see this is this is a real problem where
the gps
you know is our reliance on gps is
destroying our sense of direction
entirely
uh and it's get i admit it's it's a
problem for me too
because i i'm at a point now where i
will use the gps even if i know where
i'm going
because now the gps will it will it will
alert you to traffic and it might
reroute you
so i'll keep it on even if i know
exactly where i'm going
and i am becoming dumber and dumber
because of it by the minute
uh and i don't have a lot of iq points
to spare as you know all right we're
gonna get to our daily cancellation in
just a second
but before we do um you know we talk
about investing and
it's really important to hedge your
investments with some gold
um and especially as we look at some of
the other the
uncertainty in the world and everything
uh well this is this is stability that
you can have but the problem is
that it's really expensive to just go
out and buy gold that's not something a
lot of people can do
so here's something new you know how the
price of gold has been skyrocketing
lately
there's a new way to buy gold through a
company called acre acre lets you
subscribe to gold bars for as little as
30 a month you pay each month and once
your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they discreetly ship they hate your gold
to your house
um acre will keep you updated on your
gold stash every month
and so that's fun as well you're getting
those updates and it ships you
once you've reached the the price
threshold and with acre they're going to
take charge of the physical delivery of
your gold it means it's going to be safe
it's going to be
in your hands safe and sound in no time
acre ships your gold directly and
discreetly to your go
to your door acre also designs their
gold in california it
sources their gold from one of the
largest mints in switzerland
um acre also just recently introduced
their new 100
per month subscription for their five
gram gold bar
uh and this is something if you have the
a goal of
investing in gold and the idea of you
know just going out and buying gold is
is
seems unattainable well then here's
here's your way of making it happen so
visit getacregold.com walsh and start
investing
in physical gold today make sure you get
go to this url though because acre is
also giving away a gold bar if you want
to qualify for this giveaway
and i think we all would like to qualify
for it you could tweet or post
why you should be the recipient of this
free gold bar and mention
at get underscore acre when you do that
again that's
get acre gold dot com slash walsh and
thank you to acre gold
for supporting the show one other thing
to mention you know uh we all are
pretty disgusted with the legacy media
especially recently with with
how they're behaving around the election
um and
we know that if we have a you know if we
have a problem with the legacy media and
we don't like what they're doing with
the election
what they've done throughout this you
know for for decades now
then that means that we have to stop
relying on it we have to start looking
at other options
um and that's where delhi wire comes in
you can get a daily wire description
subscription and look we've got big
plans for the next four years and it
starts today candace owens
new york times bestselling author
founder of blexit foundation is joining
the daily wire we made that announcement
a couple weeks ago very excited about
that
she'll be launching a brand new show
with us she'll also be writing for the
site
we'll be launching an internet
entertainment channel as well a new
investigative journalism team
building partnerships as well with
like-minded creators like prageru
whose entire show library by the end of
the year will be available on
dailywire.com so it's another perk
you'll get
and right now just so you know we're
serious we're offering 25 off all
memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com subscribe and
members get all the perks that we always
talk about they get our articles ad free
access to our whole show library three
hours of ben shapiro show
exclusive readers past content and if
you up the ante and become an
all access member you also get to take
part in our all-access
shows and discussions which we live
stream every night
and those are a lot of fun as well so
remember that's 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy media with
the daily wire you won't regret it
go there now dailywire.com all right
time for our daily cancellation
today we're going to cancel and this
really shouldn't be a thing i have to
cancel but i do we're going to cancel
hugging stations or hugging curtains or
hugging tarps
whatever increasingly creepy name you
want to give it
i've seen many videos of these things
going viral recently and
here's here's a taste of it here's what
they look like our news cameras were
rolling to capture her hugging her
four-year-old grandson for the first
time
and what felt like forever
[Music]
proving at a time of such uncertainty we
all feel better
after getting a hug it was so genuine
didn't even know there was a plastic
between us
really we all needed it so badly oh yes
oh yes if you miss hugging your grandma
during the coronavirus pandemic
you're not alone this is what love is
all about
and this is precious great grandma rose
is used to hugging her granddaughter
carly
and her great grandchildren all the time
i see them every day normally
so this was kind of a challenge not to
be able to see him not to be able to hug
him
so carly came up with an ingenious
invention that looks like something
straight out of the boy in the plastic
bubble
i was getting sort of to the point of
oh my gosh i just can't handle this i
just need to hug her the kids need to
hug her
sheets of plastic protect 85 year old
rose and let everyone have a hug without
potentially spreading the virus
my arms go through the top one
[Laughter]
how amazing is this
[Music]
yeah i'll tell you right now i would
rather die of covid than take any part
in anything like that
and it's not like these things are meant
to protect the children children are not
at much risk from covet
this is about protecting the adults even
though children also are not much risk
to spread covet either
but this is really just an extreme
manifestation of the paranoia and
suspicion that has gripped hold of our
society
thanks to the coveted fear-mongering
from the media people are treating each
other
like they're radioactive even their own
family members even their own children
and grandchildren
and you know it's gotten bad when i'm
complaining about it because i already
treated people
like they were radioactive before covet
hit yet as antisocial as i am
even i'm looking around at this and
saying okay it's too much guys this is
too much
the other day i went to get on an
elevator and um elevators are very
contentious now as i walk towards it the
person on the elevator started pushing
the close button furiously so that it
would shut me out before i could get on
it
it was like something out of a horror
movie and i was the monster they were
trying to escape
now granted this may have been because
it was just me specifically they were
trying to avoid or it could have been
someone who hates elevator small talk
like i do
but when i'm trying to shut somebody out
of the elevator i do it discreetly
you know they shout hey can you hold
that and i pretend i'm hitting the open
door button but i'm really hitting the
closed door button so it's like sorry
it's closing i don't know what i'm i
don't know why i'm sorry i
i was looking forward to spending this
time with you i'm sorry this is so
unfortunate you'll have to catch the
next one all right see you later
but these days people are much less
discreet
in treating everyone else like they're
diseased and dangerous
we've all been in the situation where
you walk a little too close to somebody
in the supermarket
and they practically dive out of the way
to avoid you
sending the tostitos end cap display
tumbling down
this is how we've been conditioned to
treat each other
when does it end okay that's the
question that the apologists for this
kind of behavior
never seem able to answer when do we go
back to being normal human beings
who can walk down the street without
wearing bandanas around our faces like
train robbers from the 1870s
when are we going to stop treating our
fellow humans like they just escaped
from a leper colony
some of us never started treating our
fellow humans that way
some of us have always acted this way
and don't appreciate our anti-social
culture
being appropriated like this but if
you're in the if you're in the category
where
you don't want to walk down the street
without a mask you can't be within arm's
reach of another person unless there's a
plexiglass barrier between you
like you're interviewing hannibal lecter
or something then i ask
when will you have had enough when will
you go
back to normal if you're hugging your
grandkids through a plastic
tarp when will you feel comfortable
dropping the tarp
i know you might think the obvious
answer is when there's a covet vaccine
well okay but just because we get rid of
covid if we ever do get rid of it
or mostly get rid of it um that doesn't
mean we're home free that doesn't mean
we're free of any disease risk
there are still lots of other
potentially deadly diseases out there
the person boarding the elevator even if
he doesn't have covid
could have a million other illnesses
your grandkids could be infected with
god knows what
little germ buckets that they are if
you're practically wearing a hazmat suit
now
because of the risk are you gonna go
back to zero precautions when the risk
is gone
because the risk will never be zero the
risk will never ever be zero there will
always be
a risk of a million different things
killing you and then guess what
i hate to spoil the ending but
eventually one of those things actually
will kill you
so again if you can't handle any risk
now
even to hug your own grandkids will you
ever be able to handle risk again
what's the limiting principle it's the
same thing with masks
if masks are as the mask advocates say
essential to stopping the spread of
disease and they work
and it's also no big deal to wear them
not too onerous
then why should we ever stop wearing
them covet or no covid
why should we ever stop by their logic
we will be wearing masks forever it will
never
end and i think that's probably exactly
what's intended
and that's why everyone involved in
perpetuating and participating
in this hysteria especially if you're
using a hugging tarp
uh and by the way pressing your face up
against plastic i don't know if that
sounds like the
the safest alternative but everyone
involved in that
is canceled that's going to do it for
today and this week have a great weekend
everybody
thanks for listening godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there
you